the brain train is a very serious  phenomenon in Africa because so many  young Africans have the opportunity to  come and study abroad at places like  Yale other universities and then you see  all this of course you need you to stay  here and work and for whatever  motivation people decide to do that that  is a personal choice and it's great but  I think that the the burden of the  development of Africa falls on others  young people so we need to think  critically about what we can do to help  create opportunities for other people I  don't want to be fifty years and sending  money home as my contribution to Africa  I want to give my time and my energy to  help mentor young people to help them to  see that they can do things that will  help them to change the environment  because we can't all sit back and say  that's the way things have been for 50  years if we don't do something things  are not going to change